hi jody hi cheryl how are you
good how are you i'm good thank you
lovely backdrop very green grass
well i'm on vacation with the family but
i mean to get to speak to you guys i was
like i'll bring out my equipment and
we're going to do this so i'm so excited
thank you congratulations on this movie
it is already getting so much buzz what
does that feel like like people are
saying it's the best movie of the summer
and you've got to see it what does that
feel like
it feels amazing you know because it's
it's been a long time waiting and i
think the longer sometimes things go the
more
you worry you know the anticipation um
is a lot but i know that we had such a
wonderful time making the film and we
had so much fun so joyous so
for it now to be really you know getting
released and
to have such positive feedback and and
also for people you know to be
they expected one thing and they're
getting another you know it's like that
you know you can't judge your book by
its cover kind of thing so it's great
it's amazing
well that's it i think this movie is
about so much more i mean people are
gaming more now than ever but this movie
combines gaming in real life and some
beautiful messages i think that i took
away from it um
was that what you know they were trying
to do do you think
well
i think the kind of heart of the movie
was always there you know there was
always it was always very grounded by
human connection and
um the human experience and kind of
community
but i i do feel that given the kind of
past year um you know we shot this
pre-covered pre-pandemic
um so i do feel that now the film has
kind of taken on a new life um because
of the experiences in which we've all
kind of gone through as a collective so
people are coming away with kind of very
um
kind of personal reactions to things you
know it's quite profound and
philosophical sometimes and it is and i
think we can kind of relate to that now
in a much greater sense yeah this movie
has you know some some
super heroes with some great
characteristics what would you say your
superhero characteristic is and what
would you say ryan reynolds superhero
characteristic is ooh
superhero characteristic
or what is your superpower as a person
and what do you think ryan's
i think i don't know i think i'm quite
easy to get on with like i feel like i
could walk into a room and and
have a laugh and get on with almost
anyone
i hope
um
and i would say ryan's
is
his ability to command a room like i
think
he is wickedly smart and he's very very
funny um honey and he
this isn't something he tries to do i
just think he has an energy that makes
people want to kind of gravitate towards
him um
so
yeah i would say that and his ability to
i mean he makes everyone laugh all the
time it's i that is probably his
superpower how would you kiss him with a
straight face i mean honestly
well i mean i also my my wig i i had a
very straight face with my my wig on
yeah i was battling a lot with my leg my
wig had a mind of its own um
so yeah but no he's lovely he's so nice
amazing well congratulations on this
movie all the best thank you so much i'm
glad you enjoyed it